der ukraine auch von moldau die
europäischen perspektiven vieler länder
die sich auf unser projekt einer
gemeinschaft demokratischer staaten
selber beziehen wollen die dazugehören
wollen und es ist etwas sehr sehr
bemerkenswertes dass es tatsächlich
gelungen ist das 27 mal ja gesagt wurde
zu der beitrittsperspektive der ukraine
dass sie sich jetzt auf diesen
schwierigen weg machen kann zusammen
auch mit moldau und dass wir
gleichzeitig nicht vergessen haben dass
wir auch den staaten des westlichen
balkans jetzt endlich ermöglichen müssen
dass ihr fast 20 jahre alter
beitrittsprozess jetzt endlich auch
final wird und zu einem ergebnis kommt
alles dass es bei diesem europäischen
rat vorangegangen
[Applaus]
gleichzeitig haben wir über die
notwendige solidarität mit der ukraine
und wie wir sie gemeinsam organisieren
finanziell humanitär aber auch mit
waffenlieferung gesprochen und das ist
auch ein großes thema gewesen als die
starken wirtschaftlichen demokratien die
g-7 in ellmau in deutschland zusammen
gekommen sind wo wir auch wieder die
frage wie reagieren wir auf diesen
brutalen krieg den russland gegen die
ukraine vom zaun vom zaun gebrochen hat
gesprochen haben und wir haben es sehr
sorgfältig getan und diese solidarität
gemeinsam organisiert wir haben das
nicht alleine diskutiert sondern mit
vielen anderen ländern in der welt
eingeladen waren auch die staats und
regierungschefs von indonesien von
indien von südafrika von senegal und
argentinien um zu zeigen es stimmt nicht
was putin erzählt dass dies ein krieg
ist und
ein konflikt zwischen den globalen
westen und dem rest sondern die
demokratischen staaten der welt nicht
nur die die sich als g7 verstehen
sondern auch die in asien und in afrika
und im süden amerikas sind einhellig der
meinung dass diese art von politik nicht
verfolgt werden kann auch wenn die
einzelnen perspektiven unterschiedlich
sind es waren gute gespräche auf
augenhöhe für eine welt die multipolar
aber auch multilaterale ist
im elmer haben wir uns auch mit den
konsequenzen dieses krieges beschäftigt
und haben gemeinsam eine internet
nationale hunger an der international
food initiative ergriffen mit der wir
beitragen wollen dazu das jetzt nicht
als folge des krieges millionen menschen
auf der welt hunger leiden müssen und
wir haben auch ansonsten solidarität
organisiert wenn es etwa um das thema
der ja noch immer nicht beendet in kurve
9 10 pandemie in der welt geht wir haben
gesprochen über die residenz von
demokratien und natürlich auch wie wir
den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten können ein großes wichtiges
thema das nur untergehakt zwischen den
staaten der welt gut funktionieren kann
und deshalb ist es ein großer
fortschritt dass der vorschlag einen
klima club der gleichgerichteten staaten
derjenigen die bis zur mitte dieses
jahrzehnts klimaneutrale industrieländer
wollen zu schaffen dass dieser vorschlag
unterstützung gefunden hat das ist das
eine weitere gute ergebnis aus diesem
g7-treffen in deutschland
und bei der nato bei der nato haben wir
für finnland und schweden die einladung
ausgesprochen dass die mitglieder
unseres verteidigungsbündnisses werden
können ein großer wichtiger schritt für
das verteidigungsbündnis für die
sicherheit im transatlantischen raum und
ganz besonders in europa aber auch ein
wichtiger schritt weil er verbunden ist
auch mit weiteren entscheidungen zur
stärkung unserer ostflanke innerhalb des
nato bündnisses aber auch verstärkung
der militärischen bereitschaft die dann
300.000 soldaten soldaten umfassen soll
ein wichtiger weg nach vorne für ein
bündnis das sich mehr rüstet für eine
gefahr die von der russischen aggression
aus der ukraine ausgeht und mehr rüstet
dafür dass das eigene territorium und
alle mitglieder der nato auch verteidigt
werden können wenn sie angegriffen
werden ein guter fortschritt
die themen die auf diesen drei gipfeln
verhandelt worden sind spielen natürlich
gleichzeitig eine rolle in brüssel und
auch hier und deshalb bin ich sehr froh
dass wir mit dem fit for fifty five
pakete im europäischen räten weiter
gekommen sind dass wir aber gleichzeitig
in dieser woche im deutschen bundestag
auch die
pakete verhandeln mit dem die
bundesregierung beschleunigung zustande
bringen will beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien deutschland will
tatsächlich sowie international
vereinbart bis zur mitte dieses
jahrhunderts klimaneutral werden bis
2045 wollen wir das als land schaffen
und deshalb brauchen wir tempo beim
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien auch
das bringen wir jetzt voran
aber es geht nicht nur darum dass wir
diese internationalen verabredungen
treffen dass wir bei dem wichtigen
vorhaben klimaneutrales industrieland zu
werden so schnell vorankommen dass wir
uns vorbereiten auf die gefahren die
herrühren aus der möglichkeit dass die
energieversorgung nicht gesichert ist
wenn russland den transit zb von gas
beeinträchtigt und wir sehen ja die
angeblich technischen gründe uns
gegenwärtig schon
beeinträchtigen sondern es geht auch
darum dass wir die folgen für die bürger
und bürger dieses landes klar im blick
haben und deshalb ist es ein guter
schritt dass wir an eine wichtige
tradition in deutschland anknüpfen die
sozialpartnerschaft dem zusammenarbeit
zwischen staat gewerkschaften
arbeitgeber und unternehmensverbänden
zusammen mit bundesbank und
sachverständigenrat darüber diskutieren
was ist zu tun damit wir die bürgerinnen
und bürger vor diesen dramatischen
preissteigerungen ihrem persönlichen
leben schützen können die konzertierte
aktion hat diese woche am montag das
erste mal getagt sie wird fortgesetzt
werden es ist eine gute kooperation und
aus ihr heraus werden wir die nächsten
schritte entwickeln 30 milliarden haben
wir jetzt entlastungspaket für die
bürgern und bürger auf den weg gebracht
mit der anhebung des grundfreibetrags
mit dem arbeitnehmer pauschale die wir
angehoben haben mit den möglichkeiten
für die pendlerpauschale die wir
verbessert haben mit einem
heizkostenzuschuss für diejenigen die
wohngeld bekommen mit 200 euro für die
empfänger von grundsicherung mit der
möglichkeit dass wir eine wöchentlich 20
euro zahlen für die kinder die in irgend
einem haushalt leben dass alle kinder
für alle kinder 100 euro gezahlt werden
dass wir eine energie geld zahlen und
dass wir die eg pauschale abgeschafft
haben herr aber das wird nicht reichen
hat und was wir jetzt brauchen ist dass
wir uns unterhaken und das ist der weg
den die konzertierte aktion beschreitet
ein guter weg für unser land
bevor wir mit der befragung beginnen
mache ich noch mal auf die besonderheit
bei der kanzler befragung nach unserer
parlamentarischen übung aufmerksam der
oder die fragestellerin hat die
möglichkeit gleich noch eine nachfrage
zu stellen zum themenkomplex nachfragen
anderer abgeordneter werden aufgrund der
mir zahlreich vorliegenden gemeldeten
fragen nicht zugelassen und bitte denken
sie daran auch die nachfragen möglichst
kurz zu halten
und ich bitte auch den kanzler seine
antworten möglichst in zeitrahmen zu
halten damit ebenso viele fragestellerin
und fragesteller dann auch zum zuge
kommen
herzlichen dank dann beginnen wir die
befragung des bundeskanzlers und zuerst
hat das wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion
der abgeordnete johann wadephul
präsidentin vielen dank für die
erteilung des wortes ich erlaube mir die
anmerkung dass es eine fragestunde ist
und wir mittlerweile eine unselige
tradition der bundesregierung erleben
die hier fast eine kleine
regierungserklärung abgibt und
vielleicht könnte die präsidentin mal
darauf hinweisen
das hier vor allen dingen den
abgeordneten gelegenheit gegeben werden
sollen fragen zu stellen bundeskanzler
sie haben den g 7 gipfel
angesprochen die g7 haben sich in ihrer
schlusserklärung zu weitreichenden
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine
nach dem krieg positiv erklärt können
sie konkretisieren welche
sicherheitsgarantien das sind schönen
dank für ihre frage die frage wie das
organisiert werden kann wird besprochen
zwischen den staaten die als g7
zusammengekommen sind aber auch all
denjenigen die bereit sind solche
sicherheits garantien zu geben
deutschland ist eines dieser länder die
dazugehören klar ist auch dass es nicht
solche sein werden die artikel 5 des
nato vertrages entsprechen sie müssen
also auf diese konkrete situation
zugeschnitten sein wir sind auch im
gespräch mit der ukraine über diese
fragen das ist alles ein prozess der
noch lange nicht abgeschlossen ist und
dessen konkretisierung deshalb auch
jetzt noch nicht vorgenommen werden kann
aber der rahmen ist damit beschrieben
ein punkt allerdings habe ich schon
wiederholt und an vielen stellen gesagt
wird sicherlich eine große rolle spielen
die hoch wirksame sanktionen die wir auf
den weg gebracht haben gegen russland
die werden immer etwas sein was wir
einsetzen können wenn es verletzung von
vereinbarungen gibt um die wir jetzt ja
immer noch erst trinken tatsächlich
findet der brutale krieg ja unverändert
statt
sie können eine nachfrage stärke schön
vielen dank für diese ersten erläuterung
die mir eine erste vorstellung davon
geben was beabsichtigt ist mir stellt
sich die frage warum sie der fragenden
journalisten der deutschen welle nicht
eine ähnliche antwort gegeben haben bei
der pressekonferenz und das so brüsk
abgewiesen haben fährt er abgeordneter
diese frage hat sich bereits so
beantwortet wie ich sie ihnen
beantwortet hatte
danke
nächste fragesteller ist aus der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen jürgen
trittin
herr bundeskanzler sie haben darauf
verwiesen dass die g7 staaten versuchen
unter ihrer führung
den herausforderungen gerecht zu werden
etwa dadurch dass der kampf gegen den
klimawandel beschleunigt wird das ist
nicht nur eine frage des klimaschutzes
sommer auch eine unabhängiger zu werden
von fossilen abhängigkeiten dafür sollen
klima clubs gegründet werden wo
diejenigen die co2 produzieren ihre
märkte auch schützen können vor anderen
die das nicht tun jetzt frage ich sie
danach hat es ein urteil gegeben das
supreme court der usa
der der amerikanischen regierung
faktisch untersagt
maßnahmen zur einen co2 preis zu
ergreifen welche chancen sehen sie vor
dem hintergrund gerade dieses urteils
diesen wichtigen markt die usa in diesem
klima coup zu bekommen und zu behalten
zunächst mal ist es so dass die
entscheidung des amerikanischen gerichts
ja die amerikanische regierung und
kongress nicht daran hindern die
notwendigen gesetze auf den weg zu
bringen mit denen sie selber
klimapolitik aktiv vorantreiben können
es ging um eine handlungskompetenz der
amerikanischen behörde und ihre freiheit
sich mit eigenen kompetenzen in dieser
frage zu bewegen das ist sicherlich
schwieriger geworden aber ich weiß
sowohl vom präsidenten als auch von
carrie der in dieser frage sei ein
sonderbeauftragter ist dass ihnen das
ein ganz wichtiges anliegen des
voranzukommen die idee des klima clubs
ist aber ohnehin dass wir uns nicht auf
einen einzigen fahrt festlegen sondern
dass wir akzeptieren und verstehen dass
es unterschiedliche farben der länder
die dort zusammen arbeiten gibt und dass
diese unterschiedliche pfade auch
tatsächlich
vernünftig und richtig zueinander passen
wenn sie das gleiche ziel verfolgen ob
die mitte des jahrhunderts klimaneutrale
wirtschaft organisieren das wollen alle
und dann wird es welche wie in europa
geben die mit co2 bepreisung arbeiten
und andere die andere wege beschreiten
wichtig ist dass das ziel ernsthaft
verfolgt wird sie können eine nachfrage
stelle treten der bundeskanzler ich habe
in dem zusammenhang noch eine nachfrage
wir sind ja konfrontiert damit dass der
wegfall russischen gases
aufgrund fehlender produktion export und
transportinfrastruktur
sehr schwierig ist
in diesem winter zu die vor diesem
hintergrund haben den g7 wie ich finde
zu recht beschlossen
dass auch die garantien und die
kreditierung von investitionen in solche
infrastruktur durch staaten der g 7
wieder möglich werden soll das erzeugt
aber einen konflikt mit dem ziel was sie
eben genannt haben 2045 klimaneutral zu
sein 2035 möglichst auch unsere
stromversorgung umgestellt zu haben ich
würde es ja nicht fragen wie wollen sie
eigentlich in diesen kreditierung und
exportkreditversicherungen eine
zeitliche limitierung einführen die
dieses ziel der dekarbonisierung bei
diesen notwendigen maßnahmen nicht in
frage gestellt wir können das sehr gut
verstehen an den eigenen herausforderung
die wir haben wir wissen wir haben jetzt
ganz aktuell die herausforderung dass
wir infrastrukturen etablieren mit den
gast nach deutschland gebracht werden
kann auf andere weise als es bisher der
fall ist wenn wir das nicht tun würden
dann würden wir es nicht sicher spürten
wir nicht gewährleisten können dass wir
immer unabhängig sind von einzelnen
importeur und deshalb machen diese
investitionen sind aber sie halten
deutschland ja nicht davon ab das
gleiche ziel weiter zu verfolgen nämlich
2045 spätestens co2 neutral zu
wirtschaften und die infrastrukturen die
wir zb hier etablieren wollen wir immer
auch mit dem blick auf die perspektive
bauen dass sie später für wasserstoff
importe zb genutzt werden können und das
ist dann gleichermaßen auch die
perspektive für viele andere länder bin
dort neue infrastrukturen
errichtet werden dann müssen sie sinn
machen bei der verfolgung des 1,5 grad
zieles dann müssen sie auch solche
perspektiven mit in den blick nehmen und
das ist auch das was sich sehr
sorgfältig ausgearbeitet aus der
verständigung der g7 ergeben aber
gleichzeitig sind sie auch eine gute
botschaft für länder wie afrika zum
beispiel genau in dieser übergangsphase
der wir uns ja befinden auch noch neue
investitionen benötigt vielen dank
nächste frage aus der fdp fraktion durch
stefan kurt ring
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler wir
stehen vor einem scherbenhaufen ihrer
politik vor allen dingen ihrer
energiepolitik ausstieg aus zwei
energieformen für die stromversorgung
ergebnis die versorgungssicherheit ist
gefährdet und wir haben mit die höchsten
preise jetzt das gleiche bei öl und gas
sie provozieren dass wir also die
gaslieferungen nicht mehr so bekommen
wie wir sie eigentlich vertraglich
gesichert haben sie sagen dass sie wohl
kein gas mehr und kein öl mehr aus
russland und dann wundern sie sich dass
von daher also einschränkungen sind also
diese realitätsferne politik erschließt
sich mir nicht vielleicht können sie
dazu was sagen und auch hier die folgen
4 56 fache der gaspreise die wir sehen
völlig unsoziale politik die sie hier
machen und die hat nichts mit dem
ukraine krieg zu tun diese hohen preise
und auch nichts mit den rohstoffpreisen
dass es ihre politik der verknappung und
warum machen sie das wir haben jetzt zum
ersten mal wohl wieder nachts
jahrzehnten eine rationierung von
warmwasser in deutschland wir konnten
wir aus den zeitungen entnehmen das wird
sich ja fortsetzen wie kommen sie dazu
eine so realitätsferne politik gegen
unsere bevölkerung zu machen
ich möchte ihre frage beantworten und
sehr klar sagen realitätsfern ist das
was sie sagen denn sie nehmen sie zur
kenntnis
sie nehmen nicht zur kenntnis dass da
wirklich ein krieg ist in der ukraine
dass russland das land angegriffen hat
das gerade unglaublich viele menschen
sterben die zuständigen ihr leben
verlieren in ihren eigenen häusern auf
den straßen auf den feldern der ukraine
dass häuser zerstört werden dörfer
städte kaputt gepumpt werden und dass
das ein furchtbarer brutaler krieg ist
und die realistisch die richtige antwort
auf diese realität ist dass wir der
ukraine die notwendige solidarität
leisten und dass wir sie finanziell
humanitär zu unterstützen und dass wir
sie auch mit waffenlieferung
unterstützen das ist eine realistische
kenntnisnahme dieser wirklichkeit und es
wäre ganz ganz falsch dem von ihnen
angesprochenen vorschlag zu folgen dass
man wegen der folgen die sie benannt
haben solche solidarität nicht leistet
um im bild zu bleiben wenn über ihren
vorschlag und ihre meinung ein
scherbengericht gehalten würde dann
würde es schlecht für sie ausfallen
ja und dann eine sache
entschuldigung die zeit war abgelaufen
aber der kollege und ich kann eine nacht
frage stellen wie können wir den
menschen in der ukraine helfen wenn wir
hier frieren der russische rubel hat
sich hat sich erholt die finanzierung
läuft es über andere schienen wenn wir
uns hier selbst schädigen mit diesen
sanktionen schädigen wir russland
überhaupt nicht wir helfen damit der
ukraine überhaupt nicht da sind zwei
völlig verschiedene dinge die nicht
zueinander passen und deswegen die frage
warum halten sie an diesen sanktionen
diese nutzlosen sanktionen fest warum
nehmen sie nicht nord stream zwei in
betrieb das wäre dann die antwort dessen
wo sie sagen ja die russen sagen sie
wollen nicht durch nordsee mainz leiden
also nehmen wir die zwei die ist schon
da sie torpedieren das aber und
überhaupt warum
öl embargo pck schwedt wir gehen dort
mit den arbeitskräften unter wenn die
bruchstraße nicht mehr mit öl beliefert
wird und das alles sind mosaik steine
für die schleichende zerstörung unseres
wohlstandes und ja das ist leider
ausdruck ihrer unsozialen politik und
wie wollen sie das den bürgern erklären
ich halte fest die afg ist nicht nur
eine rechtspopulistische partei sondern
auch die partei russlands und das
sollten alle verdanken
[Musik]
und ansonsten ist es so dass wir uns ja
genau auf diese situation vorbereitet
haben wir haben sorgfältige
vorbereitungen getroffen dass wir unsere
kohle versorgung sicherstellen können
wird mit importen aus aller welt und
eben nicht aus russland wir treiben wir
treffen vorsorge dafür dass wir auf die
ölimporte verzichten können die sind
schon erheblich zurückgegangen und wir
arbeiten daran dass es andere import
wege gibt als die die bisher
eingeschlagen worden sind es wird ihn
nicht entgangen sein dass eine der
raffinerien im osten deutschlands von
sich aus längst entschieden hat sich
andere import rege zu organisieren und
was den gasimport betrifft ist es so
dass wir jetzt alles tun dafür dass wir
einerseits die vertraglichen lieferung
bekommen die uns unverändert weiter
zugesichert werden und dass wir
gleichzeitig dafür sorge tragen dass die
jahrzehntelange abhängigkeit von wenigen
importeuren dadurch beendet wird dass
wir die infrastrukturen braun bauen dass
wir von allen beliefert werden können
und das ist wirkliche energiesicherheit
für deutschland im sinne aller
bürgerinnen und bürger
nächste frage stellt aus der fdp
fraktion christoph meyer
studenten
herr bundeskanzler im letzten monat
stiegen die verbraucherpreise in
deutschland um über 7 das stellt eine
große herausforderung für viele menschen
da sie haben in ihren eingangs statement
auch darauf hingewiesen
diese ohnehin schon hohen belastungen
werden für viele menschen noch
verschärft dadurch dass mittelbar durch
die inflation die einkommen zu einem
höheren steuersatz führen und vor diesem
hintergrund möchte ich sie fragen ob sie
der auffassung sind dass der ausgleich
der kalten progression im
einkommensteuertarif notwendig ist in
diesem jahr schönen dank für diese frage
ich will gerne sagen dass wir mit den
beiden entlastungspaket die wir bereits
auf den weg gebracht haben und zwar
bevor es eine sehr energische
öffentliche debatte dazu gegeben hat
gezeigt haben dass wir die
herausforderung für die einzelnen
bürgerinnen und bürger kennen und dass
wir den die bürgerinnen und bürger und
auch die unternehmen in diesem land
nicht alleine lassen wollen die 30
milliarden die jetzt stück für stück
tatsächlich erst bei allen beteiligten
ankommen diese 30 milliarden sind ein
ganz deutliches zeichen der tat das in
dieser frage wichtig ist denn es darf er
nicht nur geredet werden und
gleichzeitig ist es aber so dass wir uns
auch fest vorgenommen haben dass wir
über das was jetzt passiert eine
verständigung weit über die regierungen
hinaus erzielen wollen wir wollen eine
verständigung erreichen mit den
sozialpartnern mit der ganzen
gesellschaft weil es hier darum geht
dass wir uns unterhaken wenn jetzt ein
großer riesiger klangteppich an
vorschlägen über alles gelegt wird dann
werden die bürgerinnen bürger nicht mehr
das gefühl haben dass wir als die
verantwortlichen das tun wozu wir
aufgefordert sind aber wenn es gelingt
ein solches bündnis anknüpfend an die
sozialpartnerschaftliche tradition
deutschlands zustande zu bringen und das
ist ja gelungen und daraus etwas zu
machen dann werden wir auch die
einzelnen schritte daraus ableiten auch
steuerliche art aber das soll sich aus
diesem bündnis ergeben sie können eine
nachfrage dank der bundeskanzler ich
glaube die entlastungs pakete die wir
auf den weg gebracht haben und auch die
konzertierte aktion sind ein sehr guter
ansatz da sind wir bei ihnen das wissen
sie
dennoch möchte ich noch mal auf die
kalte progression zurück kommen und
darauf zurückkommen ob sie den
finanzminister ähnlich wie sie selbst
als die finanzminister waren bei der
vorlage des provisions berichtes im
herbst unterstützen werden dass daraus
dann steuerentlastung
resultieren oder nicht danke für den
hinweis dass ich als finanzminister
mehrfach dazu beigetragen habe dass die
kalte progression ausgeglichen wird und
deshalb ist das eine haltung mit der die
bundesregierung sicherlich insgesamt die
dinge betrachtet trotzdem gilt dass wir
hier eine verabredung getroffen haben
die ich für ganz ganz wichtig halt und
zwar gar nicht als verabredung der
regierung sondern als verabredung der
gesellschaft dass wir versuchen jetzt
wegzukommen von jeder morgen einen neuen
vorschlag und hinzu kommen zu einer
situation in der aus der konzertierten
aktion und aus dem gespräch mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses landes
die neuen vorschläge für das was
demnächst zu tun ist wenn die preise
weiter steigen erwachsen und das ist das
konzept das wir verfolgen und es wird
ein gemeinsames handeln der regierung
geben schnell zügig zielgerichtet
nächste fragestellerin aus der fraktion
die linke janine wissler
herr bundeskanzler laut armutsbericht
des paritätischen gesamtverbandes ist
die armut in deutschland auf einen neuen
höchstwert höchstwert gestiegen der die
armutsquote liegt bei 16,6 prozent das
sind 13,8 millionen menschen die von
armut betroffen sind mehr als jedes
fünfte kind lebt in armut und diese
zahlen beschreiben ja die situation von
20 21
das heißt also bevor wir die
dramatischen preissteigerungen erlebt
haben und wir wissen dass die preise für
nahrungsmittel seit dem letzten jahr um
fast 13 prozent gestiegen sind im
internet schildern menschen unter der
überschrift ich bin armut betroffen
davon dass sich die dinge des täglichen
bedarf sich leisten können dass sie
teilweise mahlzeiten ausfallen lassen
und der paritätische fordert ja eine
deutliche erhöhung der grundsicherung
aber bei der bundesregierung gibt es
bisher überhaupt keine signale dass man
die hartz iv regelsätze schnell erhöhen
will und deshalb meine frage der
bundeskanzler glauben sie dass man mit
einem regelsatz von 449 euro über den
monat kommen kann glauben sie dass man
von 285 euro ein kind über den monat
bringen kann und wenn nein was tun sie
dann um den betroffenen schnell zu
helfen um sie schnell zu unterstützen
und auch dauerhaft
vielen dank für ihre frage und
ich glaube das ist das was sie wissen
wollten ist das viel geld nein in keinem
fall das ist etwas wo man hat rechnen
muss und das tun viele bürgern und
bürger die mit so wenig geld auskommen
müssen neben den leistungen die sie für
die finanzierung ihrer wohn unterkunft
aus der grundsicherung zum beispiel
bekommen und deshalb ist es ja so dass
die regierung aktuell in dieser krise
gehandelt hat mit einigen der maßnahmen
die ich vorhin schon aufgezählt habe und
die ganz wichtig sind viele haben auch
von den erleichterungen profitierte mit
dem neuen euro ticket jetzt drei monate
verbunden sind und den tank rabatt auch
das hat vielen geholfen aber
gleichzeitig ist es so dass wir eben
ganz konkret 200 euro für
grundsicherungsempfänger mert einmalig
zahlen dass wir für kinder die in armen
verhältnissen leben mehr zahlen 20 euro
pro monat dass wir für jedes kind 100
euro zahlen und das sind wichtige
unterstützungsleistungen neben dem
heizkostenzuschuss den wir über das
wohngeld auskehren und alles das findet
ja jetzt erst allmählich statt
gleichzeitig ist klar dass es die
regelmäßige anpassung der bezüge für
grundsicherungsempfänger gibt und da
werden die preisentwicklung die wirths
haben eine große rolle spielen müssen
aber klar ist auch dass wir uns ohnehin
eine grundlegende reform vorgenommen
haben zwei sogar die hier sehr relevant
sind nämlich dass wir gesagt haben wir
werden perspektivisch ein bürgergeld
einführen das dazu beitragen soll dass
wir ein besseres system der absicherung
für diejenigen haben die es brauchen und
dass wir die perspektive verfolgen einer
grundsicherung für kinder die anders und
gerechter bemessen dass viele leistungen
zusammenfasst und deshalb ist im
vorgriff darauf ja auch jetzt jeden
monat die erhöhung der leistung und 20
euro erfolgt sie sehen also das thema
bewegt uns und wir sind dran
sie können eine nachfrage stellen ja
dann eine nachfrage also der hartz iv
regelsatz ist ja in diesem jahr noch um
drei euro erhöht worden der für kinder
norm 2 und wir haben ja das problem
nicht nur grundsicherungs bezug sondern
auch die beschäftigten wo die inflation
natürlich voll durchschlägt und viele
durchschnittsverdiener und das ganz
besonders natürlich die niedriglohn die
menschen im niedriglohnbereich durch die
hohen preise enorm belastet sind jetzt
haben sie ja eingeladen die
gewerkschaften und die
unternehmerverbände ins kanzleramt zu
gesprächen und haben ja auch eben noch
mal gesagt dass sich jetzt alle
unterhaken sollen für die beschäftigten
bedeutet das ja erfahrungsgemäß nichts
gutes wenn ein regierungschef sagt man
braucht jetzt eine kraftanstrengung und
man solle sich unterhaken und gerade
auch angesichts der tatsache dass sehr
viele unternehmen in den letzten jahren
ja auch gute gewinne gemacht haben wenn
wir an die energieunternehmen denken
oder an den lebensmittel einzelnen
handel und andere wo es ja eigentlich
höchste zeit wäre dass die beschäftigten
auch durch vernünftige lohnsteigerungen
beteiligt würden deswegen meine frage
könnten sie mal konkretisieren was sie
mit unterhaken meinen also meinen sie
nach dem vorbild der konzertierten
aktion von 967 lohnzurückhaltung der
gewerkschaften in den anstehenden
tarifrunden und die dann wohl wo es
jetzt um die frage der steuerfreien
einmalzahlungen geht die aber ja nicht
nachhaltig sondern auch nicht auf die
rente angerechnet werden von daher meine
frage könnten sie konkretisieren was
gemeint was genau sie unter unterhaken
meinen und was da ihre vorstellung ist
schön dank glaube dass man auch
versuchen sollte sich aus der welt der
eigenen vorurteile irgendwann mal zu
befreien es ist immer nie zu spät im
leben dass irgendwann mal zustande zu
bringen und die empfehlung möchte ich ja
auch gern loswerden das zweite ist ich
glaube dass es völlig richtig ist ich
glaube dass es völlig richtig ist zu
sagen dass die konzertierte eine
notwendige aktivität traktion notwendige
aktivität des unter hakens ist dass es
keine bedrohung sondern das empfinden
viele bürgern und bürger als genau das
wozu ist gemeint ist nämlich sie nicht
alleine zu lassen angesichts der großen
preissteigerungen
es geht nicht darum dort
tarifverhandlungen zu führen das habe
ich schon bei der vorstellung dieses
vorschlags im deutschen bundestags
gleich dazu gesagt weil ich ja weiß
welche vorurteile in der welt irgendwo
gepflegt werden es geht hier darum den
bürgern und bürgern den arbeitnehmern
und arbeitnehmern zu helfen das wird
auch aus diesem zusammenschluss gelingen
und eine sache muss ich noch sagen wir
haben ganz konkret etwas dafür getan
dass sich löhne verbessern im oktober
wird der mindestlohn auf 12 euro
angehoben eine große leistung die gerade
die im blick hat die viel arbeiten wenig
geld verdienen
nächste frage stellen aus der
spd-fraktion russia
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler wir haben jetzt schon ein
paar mal über die konzertierte aktion am
montag gesprochen sie haben
gewerkschaften arbeitgeberverbände und
die bundesbank zusammen gebracht sie
haben gemeinsam beraten über die
auswirkungen der inflation und welche
maßnahmen ergriffen werden könnten um
die abzufedern unsere meine frage an der
stelle ist wie geht es jetzt konkret
weiter und wann können wir mit den
nächsten treffen rechnen also schon dank
für die frage ist es so dass wir uns
regelmäßig weiter treffen wollen immer
was das thema preissteigerung betrifft
die große veränderung die wir in unserer
gesellschaft mit den industriellen
investitionen vorhaben findet ihr in der
allianz für transformation stadt auch da
werden wir uns viermal treffen aber das
ist ein anderes thema wie wir das
hinkriegen die digitalisierungs aufgaben
die frage der klimaneutralität zu lösen
in diesen
treffen der konzertierten aktion geht es
darum wie wir den bürgerinnen und
bürgern unternehmen helfen können
angesichts der riesigen preissteigerung
und wie gesagt das nächste treffen wird
auch bald stattfinden september und die
zeit dazwischen werden wir für viele
gespräche untereinander nutzen um das
gut vorbereitet zu machen und das wird
dann auch sicher weitere fortsetzungen
geben es ist aus meiner sicht der weg
wie das gelingen kann der kooperativ
muss der sozialpartnerschaft gehört zu
den starken traditionen unseres landes
sie hat auch dazu beigetragen dass es
bei uns besser zugeht als in vielen
anderen ländern dass wir einen starken
sozialstaat haben und eine
leistungsfähige wirtschaft und darauf
müssen wir aufbauen
sie können eine nachfolge stellen das
mache ich sehr gerne vielen dank frau
präsidentin herr bundeskanzler eine
nachfrage welche ökonomische und
fiskalische strategie ist denn jetzt in
deutschland und auch in der eu angezeigt
und haben sie in schloss elmau darüber
beraten mit den g 7
die strategie um die es jetzt geht ist
dass wir alle die notwendigen
investitionen tätigen die wichtig sind
damit wir uns unabhängig machen von der
nutzung fossiler ressourcen darüber
besteht große einigkeit und das ist das
was ja auch mit der idee des klima clubs
verbunden ist
man nämlich versucht unterschiedliche
wege zusammenzuführen für dieses
ehrgeizige gemeinsame ziel und
gleichzeitig wird es dann darum gehen
dass wir diejenigen die unterstützung
brauchen auch nicht alleine lassen das
gilt in unseren ländern aber das gilt
natürlich auch im hinblick auf die ganze
welt dass wir die international food
airlines auf den weg gebracht haben dass
wir sagen wir üben solidarität auch bei
der entwicklung von energiepreisen für
viele dieser länder ist ein zeichen
dafür dass wir die welt als ganzes in
den blick nehmen damit sie
zusammenarbeit noch das ist eine der
ökonomischen verabredung in emma
nächste fragestellerin aus der cdu csu
fraktion dr anja weisgerber
herr bundeskanzler mir ist aufgefallen
dass sie bei kritischen fragen von
frauen eher belehrend antworten anders
als bei männern jetzt zu meiner ganz
konkreten frage der deutsche bundestag
hat im april diesen jahres beschlossen
auch mit den stimmen der cdu csu
fraktion und der ampel
regierungsfraktionen das im anschluss an
das eu embargo für kohle ein konkretes
ausstiegskonzept für russische öl- und
gasimporte auf den weg gebracht wird
dieses konkrete konzept liegt bis heute
nicht vor und droht im winter eine mange
lage sowohl bei gas als auch bei strom
das wird man auch bei den preisen merken
und deswegen frage ich sie ganz konkret
wann legen sie dieses ausstiegskonzept
wie vom bundestag beschlossen vor die
entscheidung sind alle vorbereiteten sie
hatten schon mehrfach gelegenheit ihr im
bundestag darüber mit abzustimmen was
die umsetzung des konzeptes betrifft
diese woche werden sie weitere
gelegenheiten dazu haben wir passen das
energie sicherungs gesetz an damit
wollen wir uns in die lage versetzen auf
mangel lagen zu reagieren wir sorgen
dafür dass kraftwerke die mit kohle
betrieben werden in den betrieb genommen
werden können damit wir gas sparen in
diesem jahr wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
anders als in früheren jahren gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist dass die speicher die
gasspeicher gefüllt werden müssen auch
die diejenigen die russischen
eigentümern gehören und wir haben durch
marktinterventionen instrumente dafür
gesorgt dass das auch tatsächlich
geschieht wir haben gleichzeitig auf den
weg gebracht dass alle sich um neue gas
lieferanten bemühen und investieren in
großem umfang zusammen mit privaten
unternehmen in neue import strukturen
für gas nach deutschland das geschieht
mit alex setzen die auch hier zur
erleichterung beschlossen worden sind
damit wir unter abkürzung alle
planungsrechtlichen restriktionen so
schnell wie möglich für die ersten
anlagen vielleicht sogar schon zum
jahreswechsel fertig sein können sie
sehen also es ist sehr umfassend agiert
worden das gilt übrigens auch für kohle
und öl war der kohle geht es im
wesentlichen darum dass die unternehmen
sich umstellen das tun sie bereits und
haben sie auch alles gut vorbereitet
nach den informationen die wir haben wir
kümmern uns mit ihnen darum dass die
transportkapazitäten der deutschen bahn
zum beispiel dafür auch genutzt werden
können und wir haben uns gleichzeitig
mit den beiden raffinerien die an die
druschba pipeline angeschlossen sind
zusammengesetzt und tun das auch weiter
um lösungen zu arbeiten
sie wissen dass leider längst sich neue
import strukturen über pipeline und
schiffe besorgt hat in diesem fall über
polen das ist kein geheimnis und die
haben also einen großen teil der
vorsorge entscheidung bereits getroffen
bei schwedt sind wir in diesen tagen
muss auch heute wieder in ganz konkreten
gespräch mit dem unternehmen und mit
vielen anderen um lösungen dafür zu
finden sie sind also wir setzen schon um
was sie als plan erst fordern
sie dürfen eine nachfrage stellen
der bundeskanzler wir brauchen aber jede
kilowattstunde und deswegen frage ich
sie ganz konkret warum nutzen sie nicht
alle optionen die wir haben warum
bremsen sie die biomasse aus und warum
lassen sie die drei kernkraftwerke die
noch am netz sind und grundlastfähig und
sicher in deutschland laufen nicht
befristet noch weiterlaufen
das ist möglich auch dank eines
gutachtens des tüv süd wurde das
bestätigt hingegen dem politisch
motivierten vermerken ihrer beiden
grünen minister ihr koalitionspartner
die fdp sieht das genauso und deswegen
frage ich sie ganz konkret wie wollen
sie diesen konflikt auch innerhalb ihrer
koalition lösen
wie sie ja gerade an der gesetzgebung
die in dieser woche im deutschen in dem
deutschen bundestag verhandelt wird
sehen können haben wir es immer
geschafft sehr gute energische
entscheidung miteinander zu treffen die
sind hier vorbereitet werden diese woche
auch stattfinden wir haben auch im
europäischen rat entsprechend gehandelt
hat es kein german vote gegeben sondern
gemeinsame aktionen auch das ist ein
zeichen für die kraftvolle
führungstätigkeit dieser regierung und
ihre einigkeit im handeln und
gleichzeitig will ich dazu sagen dass
wir natürlich uns fachlich und ganz
unideologisch mit solchen fragen
beschäftigen deshalb ist es so dass wir
ja für die zeit um die es uns jetzt
zuallererst geht nämlich dieses jahr die
atomkraftwerke laufen haben sie werden
gerade in diesem sommer gebraucht damit
möglichst viel strom von ihm produziert
wird und wir deshalb auf gas als
produktions quelle verzichten können wie
sie sicher wissen geht es ohnehin nur um
stromproduktion wenn man die
atomkraftwerke betrachtet das was wir an
heizenergie brauchen was wir an prozess
energie für die unternehmen brauchen das
kann dadurch gar nicht ersetzt werden es
geht also nur um einen kleinen teil der
stromproduktion und da sind die
fachleute der ministerien mit ihrer
expertise zu anderen erkenntnissen
gekommen als die die sie in ihrer frage
untergebracht haben
nächste frage
kommt aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen von stephan schmidt
vielen dank frau vorsitzende sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler nächste
woche jährt sich die flutkatastrophe im
aartal morgen werden wir dazu
ausführlich im plenum diskutieren die
katastrophe ist eine schmerzliche
mahnung an uns dass die klimakrise in
vollem gang ist extremwetterereignisse
uns überall und unvermittelt treffen
können zehntausende menschen haben
angehörige haben freunde haben nachbarn
verloren
zusätzlich zu diesen schicksal
schicksalsschlägen standen viele
menschen auch vor dem finanziellen ruin
es war gut und richtig dass hier bund
und länder mit mehreren milliarden euro
geholfen haben gleichzeitig müssen wir
aber auch darüber reden dass eben
staatliche ad hoc hilfen keine
verlässliche auch keine gerechte lösung
sind und dass nur knapp die hälfte aller
wohngebäude gegen elementarschäden
versichert sind sie selbst herr kanzler
zeigten ja vor einem jahr grundsätzlich
offen für eine verpflichtende
elementarschadenversicherung haben
damals darauf verwiesen die länder
müssten sich einigen und dann würde der
bund dem sicher nicht entgegenstehen
jetzt gibt es ja eine einigung die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat die
einführung einer pflicht versicherung
gegen elementarschäden empfohlen stehen
sie also noch zu ihrer aussage und wie
würden sie da konkret vorgehen
insbesondere auch um soziale härten
entgegenzutreten
schönen dank für diese frage in der tat
ist es so dass das wichtigste hemmnis
für eine elementarversicherung in diesem
bereich immer gewiss dass das keine
einigung unter den 16 ländern darüber
gegeben hat ob überhaupt das ist jetzt
der große fortschritt dass wir den
wunsch der länder dass überhaupt mal zu
denken bekommen haben jetzt wird
natürlich darüber gearbeitet werden der
zuständige minister hat sich auch diese
aufgabe gewidmet und wird dazu
vorschläge für die länder diskussion mit
den ländern präsentieren aber es ist
ganz klar
dass das mit der grund absicht dass es
eine elementarschadenversicherung geben
soll die verpflichtend ist noch nicht
getan ist denn das bedeutet ja dass man
einen weg finden muss um zu gehen mit
unterschiedlichen risiken dass man einen
weg finden muss um zu gehen mit
unterschiedlichen betroffenheiten und
das alles aufzulösen so dass auch am
ende noch weiterhin 16 länder zustimmen
wird eine große herausforderung sein
aber der wunsch ist geäußert und die
bundesregierung wird hilfreich tätig
sein
sie können eine nachfrage stellen
tatsächlich ist ja die kehrseite der
versicherung bzw der pflichtversicherung
die prävention da würde mich noch
interessieren welche vorschläge sie für
bessere prävention von elementarschäden
und maßnahmen zur klimafolgen anpassung
gerade auch im blick auf eine reform des
katastrophenschutzes und eine stärkung
der bundesebene in diesem zusammenhang
auf ihrem arbeitspensum haben
es gibt verschiedene themenfelder die
damit angesprochen sind das eine
themenfeld ist ganz sicher die frage wie
wir im rahmen unserer bauplanung im
rahmen von
stadtplanung von
landschaftsplanung sicherstellen dass
raumordnungsplan um sicherstellen dass
solche gefahren mit eingepreist und
beachtet werden das ist aber eine
langfristige perspektive weil angesichts
bei ihrer tausende gewachsener
siedlungsstrukturen da ja nicht von
einem tag auf den anderen einfache
lösungen da sind die auch im einklang
mit der bevölkerung möglich sind das
wird also der eine aspekt seien dort
langfristig zusammen mit denjenigen die
vor ort tätig sind lösungen und wege zu
finden die aber nicht von einem tag auf
den anderen sicher umgesetzt werden und
der zweite ist dass wir sicherstellen
dass unsere katastrophenschutz
infrastrukturen in den gemeinden in den
ländern und im bund gut funktionieren
sie wissen dass wir förderprogramme für
ganz klassische warnung haben die sich
mit sachen verbinden sie wissen dass wir
neue möglichkeiten die sich aus funk und
digitalem ergeben nutzen wollen und das
alles zusammen soll eine verbesserte
sicherheitsarchitektur schaffen auch in
dem wir überprüfen und sicherstellen
dass die katastrophenschutz
institutionen gut ausgerüstet sind um
auch im einzelfall zureichende hilfe
leisten zu können
nächster fragesteller aus der afg
fraktion klaus stöber
frau präsidentin sagte der bundeskanzler
vielen dank der sie heute zeit gefunden
haben für diese fragestunde im gegensatz
zu ihren finanzminister der ist ja
vorgezogen hat lieber seine hochzeit auf
sylt zu zelebrieren
ich habe eine frage zur inflation sie
haben das ja nie allein leiden wurden
erwähnt das ist ja wirklich das problem
was die menschen im moment am meisten
bewegt ist ja nicht nur der spritpreise
sind ja auch die von steigenden
energiepreise preise für gas preise für
lebensmittel viele wissen wirklich nicht
mehr wie sie ihre täglichen kosten
bestreiten sollen und
man muss auch sagen interessiert und
wollen dieses problem stehen das haben
sie auch schon angedeutet hat das ja
schon mal angedeutet dass wir das
problem haben werden das vielleicht auch
gar kein gas mehr da ist um die leute
mit wärme zu versorgen
und da muss man ja wohl feststellen dass
ihre sanktionspolitik gegenüber russland
gescheiteres sie wollten putin schaden
aber sie haben ihren eigenen volk
geschadet und da muss man ja die frage
stellen wie sie das als bundeskanzler
mit ihrem amt zum wohl des deutschen
volkes in übereinstimmung bringen können
und sie haben ja auch die frage der
kollege von der spd angeführt dass diese
konzertierte aktionen jetzt kabel läuft
und dann sagen sie wollen sich der
regelmäßig treffen herr kanzler haben
sie schon mal draußen informiert wie
jemand situation auf der straße ist ich
glaube die leute haben keine zeit dass
sie sich dann alle vier wochen mal
trafen
kommentieren konkret meine antwort
wissen deswegen wäre meine frage gibt es
schon konkrete ergebnisse diese möchten
unsere dem volk vor lesen vorlesen
können sollen
schönen dank für ihre frage natürlich
habe ich mich ganz praktisch informiert
welche auswirkungen das gibt und deshalb
sage ich viele bürgerinnen bürger haben
nicht genügend rücklagen und auch die
plötzlichen preis steigen die zb auf
ihre energierechnung zu kommen können
aber auch auf viele preissteigerung im
täglichen leben reagieren zu können
deshalb haben wir bereits zwei pakete
auf den weg gebracht über insgesamt 30
milliarden euro ich habe jetzt bereits
mehrfach einzelne aspekte davon
aufgezählt das ist wirklich viel und
manches davon haben viele noch gar nicht
zur kenntnis genommen und bemerkt weil
das noch gar nicht ausgezahlt ist und
noch nicht angekommen ist allein die
reduzierung der stromrechnung um 20
milliarden euro dadurch dass die
eeg-umlage jetzt jahr für jahr entfällt
das ist ein schritt der vielen nützen
wird privaten haushalten auch den
unternehmen und die vielen anderen die
ich aufgezählt haben instrumente werden
ihren eigenen beitrag leisten wir finden
aber das gewissermaßen mit diesen beiden
schritten nicht alles getan ist und
während die gerade erst umgesetzt werden
fangen wir schon richtigerweise die
diskussion darüber an was eigentlich in
zukunft zu tun ist damit wir
zurechtkommen können damit alle
bürgerinnen und bürger zurecht kommen
können und das ist das konkrete ziel der
konzertierten aktion
ich sage nochmal wenn gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeberverbände wenn der staat wenn
die bundesbank der sachverständigenrat
gemeinsam diskutieren und vorschläge
entwickeln dann ist das das beste was
wir in deutschland haben die
sozialpartnerschaft hat deutschland
stark gemacht und sie wird und selbst
als land auch in zukunft weiter stark
machen
[Applaus]
ich sage einen schönen guten tag und
frage wollen sie eine
nachfrage ja ich muss schon mal konkret
festlegen an einer maßnahme die
regierung ja schon beschlossen hat sie
so genannte der energiepreis pauschale
bürger im tipp jeder erwerbstätige traut
rohstoff richtig erhalten soll ich kann
nicht erwarten dass sie sich mit jedem
gesetz intensiv auseinandersetzen aber
vielleicht hat ihn ja einer ihrer
kollegen aus der spd-fraktion mal
berichtete wie die anhörungen
finanzausschuss zu diesem thema das der
energiepreis pauschale von fast 1
experten heftig kritisiert wurde nicht
nur hinsichtlich der praktischen
umsetzbarkeit sondern auch der fakt dass
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen komplett
aus dieser energiepreis pauschale
ausgegrenzt wurden und auch fragt sie
jetzt mal nicht als kanzler sondern als
sozialdemokrat wie sie es verantworten
können dass bei der energiepreis
pauschale zb 21 millionen rentner
einfach mal vergessen worden und da war
sie auch als kanzler wie sie es mit sich
vereinbaren können dass jemand monats
35.000 euro anspruch haben auf dauer
energie preis pauschale und 21 millionen
rentner haben keinen anspruch die frage
wirklich gegangen darstellen vielen dank
für ihre frage in der tat haben wir ganz
viele maßnahmen ergriffen die sich an
verschiedene richten viele haben auch
direkte auswirkungen für renten und
rentner auch von den maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben ganz besonders für
diejenigen die zum beispiel auf
grundsicherung angewiesen sind sie
profitieren auch von der einmalzahlung
die wir direkt leisten es ist so dass
wir gleichzeitig mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss auch denjenigen
helfen die
wohngeld bekommen und wir haben darüber
hinaus ja gerade jetzt eine
substanzielle länder rentenerhöhung wir
haben gerade in diesem bundestag
beschlossen auch das wird umgesetzt eine
massive anhebung viele
erwerbsminderungsrente dadurch dass wir
die zurechnungszeiten verändert haben
und dort viele etwas bekommen noch wird
die grundsicherung umgesetzt und wir
haben gleichzeitig als regierung auch
beschlossen steht auch in der
vereinbarung über die bildung der
regierung dass wir das rentenniveau
stabilisieren wollen es wird also sehr
viel getan für renten und rentner und
trotzdem sagen wir nicht dass damit
schon alles getan ist und wir werden das
weiter in den blick nehmen das ist eine
der aufgaben der konzertierten aktionen
und der diskussion die wir uns
vorgenommen haben dass wir ein
gesamtkonzept entwickeln für das was als
nächstes zu tun ist nun können sie sich
sicher sein wir werden alle im blick
haben und nicht nur einige
die nächste frage gestellt übrigen
produkte jurisch
dank frau präsidentin sehr geehrter herr
bundeskanzler
ich möchte sie gerne zum thema
personalmangel arbeitskräfte
knappheit befragen die aktuelle personal
not an den flughäfen ist ja nur die
spitze von einem riesengroßen eisberg
egal mit wem man spricht in der
gastronomie im handwerk in der industrie
überall fehlen arbeitskräfte
wir sind eine alternde gesellschaft und
die demografie wird immer mehr zu einem
ganz großen problem für uns und zu einem
wachstumshemmer bewährtes problem der
personalknappheit nicht allein aus dem
inland heraus beheben können experten
sagen wir brauchen bis zu 400.000
gezielte einwanderung zuwanderung in pro
jahr und damit steigender tendenz und
die koalition hat sich ja auch einen
paradigmenwechsel im bereich der
migrationspolitik vorgenommen in
richtung von einem modernen
einwanderungsland mit einem
gestaltungsanspruch
wo wir vorausschauend und auch
realistisch migration planen wollen und
deswegen möchte ich sie gerne fragen was
plant die bundesregierung um den großen
bedarf an arbeitskräften zu decken und
dass wir uns auch im internationalen
wettbewerb um arbeitskräfte behaupten
können vielen dank
dank für ihre frage zunächst einmal
haben wir die herausforderung sowieso
seit vielen jahren schon und deshalb
geht es immer darum wie wir dazu
beitragen dass möglichst viele in diesem
land beschäftigt sind auch zu guten
bedingungen ich glaube dass sich die
lage auch verbessern wird zum beispiel
durch die einführung des mindestlohns
von hat das war das schon passiert und
wenn er jetzt auf 12 euro angehoben wird
wird das dazu beitragen dass für viele
die arbeit etwas attraktiver wird als
sie bisher ist auch das wird auf den
arbeitsmarkt auswirkungen haben was die
korona pandemie uns gezeigt hat ist dass
viele die ihre arbeitsplätze aufgeben
mussten weil sie zu schlecht bezahlt
waren oder weil sie nicht mehr
weiterbeschäftigt wurden sich etwas
neues gesucht haben was neues gefunden
haben was auch besser war und deshalb
nicht zurückkehren an ihre alten
arbeitsplätze
das ist übrigens auch einer der gründe
für die schwierigkeiten die wir jetzt an
den flughäfen haben dass du zu viele
weggeschickt wurden dass die
arbeitsbedingungen nicht so attraktiv
waren dass diejenigen die weggeschickt
wurden oder die sich wegen der
wirtschaftlichen lage was neues gesucht
haben jetzt zurückkehren und darum wird
es zu den maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
auch gehören dass wir nicht nur erlauben
dass die fluggesellschaften aus dem
ausland zu tariflöhnen beschäftigte
hierher holen und direkt einstellen bei
denen die hier vor ort tätig sind
sondern es wird auch dazu gehören dass
man generell bessere arbeitsbedingungen
diesem bereich schafft aber wir brauchen
auch zuwanderung von fachkräften in
deutschland und deshalb ist es eines der
großen modernisierungsvorhaben diese
regierung dass wir mit erheblichen
fortschritten bei der gesetzgebung dazu
beitragen dass fachkräfte einwanderung
nach deutschland einfacher wird auch das
wird dazu beitragen dass der
arbeitsmarkt in deutschland sich
entspannt dass mehr leute beschäftigung
finden
sind noch eine bitte sehr vielen dank
der möchte ich direkt anknüpfen die
freien demokraten haben ja schon länger
in ihrem wahlprogramm auch gefordert
dass wir eine chancen karte auf der
basis von einem punktesystem haben und
das haben wir auch im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart die auch gerade für auch für
die jobsuche in einwanderung ein
einreise nach deutschland ermöglicht auf
der grundlage von klaren kriterien und
da wollte ich sie mal fragen wie
prioritär wollen sie dieses thema
behandeln und dann können wir damit
einen gesetzgebungsvorschlag rechnen
damit wir da damit wir da weiter
vorankommt im sinne von einem modernen
einwanderungsland vielen dank die
bundesministerin feser und der
bundesminister heil wollen noch in
diesem jahr vorschläge zu dem bereich
machen und die werden genau das
beinhalten worauf sie angesprochen haben
nämlich einerseits eine weitere
verbesserung des bestehenden rechts der
fachkräfte zuwanderung das in
deutschland existiert wir haben wie
fachleute wissen eines der großzügigsten
rechts regime in dieser frage aber es
ist ein wissen das sich auf wenige
beschränkt deshalb ist die effizienz
unserer bisherigen fachkräfte
zuwanderung nicht so groß wie sie sein
könnte und gleichzeitig neben der
beseitigung von hürden und
schwierigkeiten die dort existieren
wollen wir dafür sorge tragen dass es
auch eine qualifizierte fach-
einwanderung gibt von männern und frauen
die noch keinen arbeitsplatz haben aber
so viel können dass es sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dass sie bald
einfinden und das ist das mit dem
punktesystem verbundene beide systeme
wollen wir zu einem guten chor renten
gesamtkonzept zusammenfügen und daraus
einen großen fortschritt für unser land
erreichen wir werden unseren wohlstand
nur erhalten können wenn wir die hohe
zahl an beschäftigten die wir heute
haben auch in zukunft sicherstellen
können das wird gelingen indem
diejenigen die hier zu lande arbeit
suchen und arbeitsfähig sind das noch
mehr tun als das bisher der fall ist
junge leute perspektiven kriegen aus dem
ausbildungsmarkt aber es gelingt auch
durch zuwanderung
die nächste frage stellt christian görke
präsidentin dass ich die frage an den
bundeskanzler richten darf
lars klingbeil als
parteivorsitzender sozialdemokratischen
partei hat in der letzten woche sehr
eindringlich dafür geworben angesichts
der bizarren gewinne von
energiekonzernen eine über gewinn steuer
zu prüfen und das hat frage ich sie
angesichts dieser klaren botschaft ihres
parteivorsitzenden sind der
sozialdemokratische kanzler ob sie sich
im kabinett dafür einsetzen werden dass
wir angesichts dieser entwicklungen und
vor allen dingen sind weitere
entlastungspaket sicherlich auch möglich
hier eine gegenfinanzierung erreichen
wie sie wissen ist
diese frage eine die sich technisch gar
nicht so einfach beantworten lässt was
man den konkret machen mag zumal ist ja
auch viele unternehmen gibt die grosse
gewinne mache aber nicht hierzulande und
auch nicht hierzulande deswegen
besteuert werden können aber unabhängig
davon handelt ich auf der basis der
entscheidung die wir miteinander
getroffen haben zur bildung dieser
regierung und den konzepten die sich
dort in dem koalitionsvertrag
wiederfinden
ich würde gerne einer nachfrage stellen
dann muss ich eben noch mal anders
anfangen sie haben ja als
kanzlerkandidat respekt und für
gerechtigkeit geworben was macht das
eigentlich mit ihrem
gerechtigkeitsgefühl wenn mark mächtige
ölkonzerne sich auf kosten der
arbeitenden bevölkerung ja so bereichern
konkret die frage finden sie diese
leistungslosen über gewinne die nur
durch die marktposition bestehen
eigentlich okay
wie sie und wie glaube ich fast alle
bürgerinnen bürger in diesem lande finde
ich es schon bedrückend zu sehen das in
einer zeit in der es für alle entwirrt
einige ganz besonders große gewinne
machen die aber der gegenwärtigen
situation geschuldet sind und deshalb
sind sie umso mehr verpflichtet dazu
beizutragen dass hier die preise nicht
durch die decke schießen das zum
beispiel wenn wir steuerliche regelungen
zur erleichterung für die bürgerinnen
bürger auf den weg bringen sie auch bei
den bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommen und
gleichzeitig ist es so dass wir im blick
haben müssen dass wir natürlich auch
einzelne unternehmen haben wo das gar
nichts mit diesen dingen zu tun hat
sondern mit technischen innovationen mit
fortschritt mit vielen leistungen die
damit verbunden sind gerade in der
korona pandemie haben wir gesehen dass
aus deutschland unternehmen mit rom
innovativen potenzial in der lage waren
uns und der ganzen welt mit ihren
fortschritten zu helfen
jetzt muss hat stellt die nächste frage
danke frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler ich möchte ihnen gerne
eine frage stellen aus dem bereich der
kinderbetreuung und bildung es ist so
dass wir wollen natürlich dass alle
kinder in unserem land die gleichen
bildungs- und entwicklungschancen
bekommen und dabei ist vor allem eine
gute betreuung eine gute
kindertagesbetreuung sehr wichtig das
hat auch gerade die krone pandemie
gezeigt ich möchte gerne fragen welche
welche wie groß oder welche wichtigkeit
hat für sie die frühkindliche bildung
und inwiefern wird der bund hier auch
zukünftig verantwortung übernehmen
die von frühkindliche bildung ist sehr
sehr wichtig und deshalb gehört es ja zu
den vorhaben dieser regierung dazu
beizutragen dass sie sich weiter
verbessert wir haben auch vorsorge
getroffen für die fortsetzung des
für die tür für eine gute
kinderbetreuung in den nächsten
haushaltsjahren und werden das
fortsetzen was wir da bisher begonnen
haben dass es wichtig für die zukunft
ja sehr gerne und zwar geht es noch mal
um das gute kita gesetz das soll ja
weiter entwickelt werden und welche
schwerpunkte
sollen ihrer meinung nach hier besonders
gelegt werden ich glaube dass es viele
schwerpunkte gibt die von den ländern
und gemeinden in dieser frage ein wenig
unterschiedlich gesehen werden es geht
um immer auch qualitätsverbesserung der
eine rolle spielt es geht um den ausbau
der kapazitäten auch das dürfen wir nie
vergessen dass es unverändert in vielen
bereichen deutschlands notwendig dass
wir mehr betreuungs kapazitäten haben es
geht auch um die frage kann man sich
diese gebühren wenn man sich das
eigentlich leisten sind kind da
hinzuschicken also auch dieses thema
kommt da rein und aus der gesamtschau
ergibt sich ein setting das wir bisher
dadurch aufgelöst haben dass wir mit den
ländern konkrete verständigung gefunden
haben über die art und weise wie sie das
umsetzen wollen und entlang dieses
pfades werden wir sicherlich weiter
marschieren
jürgen hardt ist der nächste freie
stellen
dass kanzler krasser themenwechsel aber
ich muss es leider ansprechen die
ukraine ist in einer extrem bedrohten
situation auch militärisch jetzt neu
unter druck gekommen sie haben am 27
februar gesagt wir müssen der ukraine
helfen wo wir können wir haben dann ende
april hier gemeinsam mit bundestag unter
den parteien der mitte festgestellt dass
wir schwere waffen liefern müssen dass
wir alles tun müssen damit
putin im druck von sanktionen einerseits
und militärischen widerstand durch die
ukraine andererseits in eine situation
kommt in der erkennt dass er diesen weg
nicht weiter gehen kann sondern auch
sich abklären muss von von dieser
politik wenn wir gucken was konkret aus
unseren beschlüssen den bundestag oder
aus der ankündigung gekommen geworden
ist haben wir allerdings einige
fragezeichen sie haben gesagt kein land
würde westliche waffen liefern das
stimmt nicht die spanier wollen leopard
2 panzer liefern auch wir haben ja im
übrigen
panzerhaubitzen geliefert aber
gleichzeitig steht auf deutsch bei
ostdeutschen rüstungsunternehmen panzer
auf dem hof schützenpanzer marder zum
beispiel die nicht in der ukraine
ausgeliefert werden können woran liegt
das wehr steht da auf der bremse schönen
dank für ihre frage wir haben sehr sehr
viel unterstützung für die ukraine
mobilisiert auch was waffen betrifft sie
wissen das haben sie gerade angesprochen
dass die panzerhaubitze nachdem wir die
soldatinnen und soldaten der ukraine
hierzulande daran ausgebildet haben
mittlerweile im einsatz sind sie haben
auch gehört dass wir weitere schicken
wollen sie haben mitbekommen dass wir
eine entscheidung getroffen haben dass
wir zusammen mit großbritannien und den
usa mehrfach raketenwerfer nach der
ukraine schicken auch da hat die
ausbildung bereits begonnen das gleiche
gilt übrigens für den flattr gepard
in der lage ist der in der lage ist
die truppen zu beschützen die aus der
luft angegriffen werden und der dazu
eine ganz ganz wichtige funktion hat und
das gilt auch für die weiteren systeme
die wir jetzt im hr bereich high-tech
liefern das ist zum beispiel ein atelier
ortungs radar cobra das ist das erste
system das wir auf den weg bringen
werden modernste
technik die dazu und auch sehr teure
technik die dazu in der lage ist ganze
städte zu schützen gegen angriffe aus
der luft und in dieser linie werden wir
auch immer weitermachen da können sie
sich darauf verlassen und gleichzeitig
ist es so dass wir eng zusammen mit
unseren verbündeten aktiv sind und wie
können sich eigentlich ungefähr daran
orientieren dass die usa oder frankreich
oder großbritannien machen wenn sie
gucken wollen was wir tun wenn sie das
abgleichen was sie längst getan haben
dann wissen sie und es könnten sie also
bestätigen wenn sie wollten dann werden
sie sehen können wir sind eingebunden
das was die verbündeten machen was die
freunde tun und wir werden weiter immer
eingebunden bleiben alleingänge gibt es
in dieser frage nicht
sie haben noch eine nachfrage in petto
herr bundeskanzler wir haben sichere
informationen dass die deutsche
rüstungsindustrie der lage wäre
modernisierte gebrauchte marder panzer
die bei ihr auf dem hof stehen an die
ukraine zu lieben und wir wissen dass
die ukraine die haben will das gleiche
gilt für transportpanzer vom typ fuchs
die frage an sie ist die haben sie eben
nicht beantwortet wer steht auf der
bremse dass es nicht zu diesen
lieferungen kommt wollen wenn sie es
nicht wollen sie die fahren dann sagen
sie ist dann müssen wir uns damit
auseinandersetzen aber diese
hinhaltetaktik finde ich nicht gut es
ist
es ist eine entschiedene
führungsentscheidung als ist eine
führungs entscheidung die wir gemeinsam
getroffen haben dass wir keine
alleingänge machen sondern immer mit
unseren verbündeten zusammenarbeiten und
deshalb kann ich ein ganz konkret sagen
wir haben jetzt mehrere ring täusche
vorbereitet wo waffen die in bei den
osteuropäischen verbündeten und freunden
vorhanden sind geliefert werden direkt
an die ukraine die zu den sowjetischen
russischen beständen die dort genutzt
werden passen wo auch genügend munition
und training vorhanden ist haben mit
mehreren ländern diese vereinbarung
jetzt soweit konkretisiert dass sie
unmittelbar mit auslieferung verbunden
sein werden und denen werden wir dann
auch solche modernisierten waffen aus
deutschen beständen zur verfügung
stellen das ist ein weg den viele
beschreiten wir haben sehr viel energie
darin investiert dass das auch passiert
und jetzt werden sie die nächsten wochen
tatsächlich immer mit der umsetzung
dieser sehr fortschrittlichen und
hilfreiche maßnahme
informiert seien darüber informiert sein
und ich glaube das wird sie dann auch
überzeugen dass wir genau den richtigen
weg gehen
herr kollege konstantin doktor
konstantin von notz stellte ex
frau präsidentin mein herr bundeskanzler
sie haben als erster kanzler dieses
landes eine botschaft an den christopher
zum christopher street day gesendet und
das ist ein außerordentliches zeichen
des respekts und der anerkennung und
dafür möchte ich ihnen für uns alle hier
sehr danken erst macht
zu recht haben sie dabei den fokus auf
die bekämpfung der quer feindlichen
hasskriminalität
gelegt der schreckliche mutmaßlich
islamistische anschlag von oslo aber
auch die gewaltattacken die tagtäglich
quirl menschen hier in deutschland
erfahren zeigen es muss hier einfach
sehr viel mehr getan werden als bisher
und deswegen frage ich sie die
innenministerkonferenz hat im dezember
20 21 einen einstimmigen beschluss
die bundesregierung in diesem
einstimmigen schluss gebeten zur
feindlichen hasskriminalität ein
unabhängiges expertengremium aus
wissenschaft und praxis unter einbindung
von fach verständigen aus der lsb
gemeinschaft einzusetzen das gremium
soll handlungsempfehlungen vorlegen wie
die bekämpfung von gegen spd
eingerichtete gewalttaten weiter
verbessert werden kann wird die
bundesregierung dieser empfehlung der
emk nachkommen und noch in diesem jahr
eine solche
expertenkommission einberufen
wir werden auf alle fälle dass wir
werden alles tun um solche pass
kriminalität zu bekämpfen dazu gehört
übrigens auch das vorhaben dass wir
entsprechende gesetzliche veränderungen
vornehmen die dazu führen dass das auch
strafrechtlich schärfer verfolgt werden
kann als das heute der fall ist wir
haben bereits
gesetzgebung die paz kriminalität zum
gegenstand hat aber nicht wenn es um
schwere personen geht übrigens auch
blick auf frauen gibt es da etwas zu
verbessern was mit der heutigen
gesetzgebung nicht verbunden ist das
werden wir tun und natürlich werden wir
arbeitsstrukturen etablieren die dazu
beitragen dass diese sachen auch weiter
untersucht werden und dass wir dazu dass
wir dazu kommen dass die richtigen
maßnahmen ergriffen werden denn neben
gesetzen wird es ja auch darum gehen
ganz konkrete praktische schritte
miteinander zu vereinbaren herzlichen
dank
keine nachfrage
mithin ist die nächste frage stellen
danke frau präsidentin sehr geehrter
herr kanzler wir sind in einer sehr
angespannten haushaltslage und die
gesamte bevölkerung leidet unter den
enormen preissteigerungen christian
lindner hat letzten freitag die
grundzüge des haushaltsplans 2023 um die
mehrere mehrjährige finanzplanung bis
2026 vorgestellt dort sind auch
entlastungen für die bevölkerung bis
2026 eingeplant und zwar insgesamt 12,7
milliarden euro rechnet man das jetzt
runter planen sie also entlastungen pro
kopf in höhe von 3 eur 19 monatlich das
kann man bestenfalls als symbolischen
beitrag werten eine richtige und last
und planen sie also ganz offensichtlich
nicht auf der anderen seite haben sie
die indische regierung zehn milliarden
euro zugesagt wie passt das zusammen
die frage passt schon nicht also
weil das ist dermaßen dass für 100 oder
sich das erlauben dazu sagen es ist
wichtig dass wir unseren internationalen
verpflichtungen nachkommen und dass wir
dazu beitragen dass zum beispiel andere
länder auch den weg eingeschlagen den
wir für die ganze welt wichtig finden
nämlich co2 neutrale wirtschaften zu
entwickeln das gelingt anderen ländern
nicht so einfach wie uns und ohne unsere
unterstützung und deshalb gehört zu den
politikern die wir machen wenn wir darum
kämpfen dass es eine industrielle
transformation zu einer co2 neutralen
zukunft gibt nicht nur dass wir uns
dafür einsetzen dass das bei uns gelingt
sondern dass auch andere länder
mitmachen die ja wenn man das pro kopf
aus rechnet sie haben so eine rechnung
auch vorgenommen dort viel weniger co2
emittieren als wir das heute tun und
trotzdem müssen wir sie davon überzeugen
dass sie nicht jetzt 200 jahre das
machen was wir die letzten 200 jahre
gemacht haben es macht also sinn und ist
gut investiertes geld in unserem eigenen
interesse damit wir auf diesem planeten
leben können und ansonsten haben sie
gesehen dass wir mit dem
haushaltsentwurf es geschafft haben
nach den jahren der korona pandemie
entsprechend den vorgaben des
grundgesetzes
haushalt 23 vorzuschlagen und auch die
finanzplanung dass wir mit den mitteln
die uns zur verfügung stellen eine
ehrgeizige politik machen können und das
in diesem rahmen ohne dass das bereits
konkretisiert ist auch steuerliche
entlastung für bürger und bürger
vorgesehen sind und so wie es im
steuerrecht der fall ist da wo wir das
machen können wir immer dafür sorgen
dass diejenigen die wenig geld haben
besser wegkommen als diejenigen die sehr
viel geld verdienen und auch das gibt
uns neue spielräume also alles passt
zusammen
und fragen stellen
da sehen wir naturgemäß anders und ich
bin auch froh dass jeder bürger dass an
seinem eigenen portemonnaie zukünftig
prüfen kann ich bin nämlich nicht so
zuversichtlich wie sie trotzdem noch mal
zurück zu indien ich hatte auch die
entwicklungshilfeministerin gefragt im
haushaltsausschuss was sind der zweck
der mittel diese zehn milliarden euro
für indien sein soll da sagte sie dass
man natürlich auch mit indien in guten
gesprächen sein muss und dass in dir
nicht nur mit china und russland
zusammenarbeiten möchte also so eine art
wirtschaftlicher balance jetzt muss ich
leider feststellen dass indien sich
nicht an den sanktionen beteiligt im
gegenteil indien kauft grad russisches
öl zu 25 30 prozent rabatt im vergleich
zum weltmarktpreis exportiert diese
kraftstoffe diese raffinieren dann auch
noch nach europa im mai sind die exporte
dar um 50 prozent gestiegen 540.000
tonnen sind es jetzt hat freitag indien
auch noch angekündigt exportzölle
einzuführen also 16 cent pro liter
anders formuliert indem beteiligt sich
nicht an den sanktionen sondern versucht
die auszunutzen bereich hat sich auch
noch daran als haushälter stellt ich mir
immer die frage ob die geplanten mittel
zum zweck pass also es sind wir in der
lage mit den zehn milliarden euro den
zweck zu erreichen wenn jetzt das ziel
war so eine wirtschaftliche balance
einzuführen mit indien muss man leider
verstehen das hat nicht funktioniert
also wenn man freche ist kann man auch
sagen die inder bereichern sich auch an
der geschichte hier sind würde ich mich
fragen möchte ich sie fragen halten sie
an den zehn milliarden euro fest und was
erhoffen sie sich zukünftig noch davon
im vergleich zu dem was die
entwicklungshilfe mindest da sagen wir
halten an unserer entwicklungspolitik
und entwicklungshilfe fest ja die frage
will ich klar beantworten aber wir haben
auch gute gründe dafür und ich glaube
dass man sich entfernen muss von dem was
letztendlich hinter ihrer frage steht
und etwas imperialistische geste
gegenüber der übrigen welt die
vorstellung nämlich das alles und alle
sich nach unseren eigenen ideen richten
ich glaube dass es sehr sehr wichtig ist
ich glaube dass es sehr sehr richtig ist
was wir machen nämlich enge gespräche zu
führen mit den freunden der welt und ich
hatte vorhin schon berichtet dass wir
die
regierungschefs und präsidenten von
indonesien indien südafrika senegal und
argentinien eingeladen hatten zu unserem
gespräch im g 7 gipfel und ich bin
dagegen dass wir akzeptieren dass es
nach den puten weltbild das ihnen ja wie
ich eben gehört habe nicht so fern ist
dass es nach dem putin weltbild eine
situation gibt in der die welt gespalten
ist in den globalen westen wir das immer
nennt und dem rest sondern die
demokratien die staaten die sich auf ein
gutes miteinander bemühen die nicht ihre
nachbarn überfallen die haben die
mehrheit und die wollen auch
zusammenarbeiten und das ist das was wir
mit unserer politik auch unterstützen
wollen und weiter unterstützen werden
ich beende die fragestunde die befragung
des bundeskanzlers nein falsche frage
schon bekommt noch bedanke mich bei
einem fragesteller innen und beim
bundeskanzler für die bereitschaft
[Applaus]